[Musique]
ça c'est mon bocal de déchets pour un
mois pour une famille de trois personnes
bon alors là je sais déjà que la salle
va se diviser en deux catégories d'un
côté il ya ceux qui disent waouh trop
fort et de l'autre pour qui c'est plutôt
à oui mais alors là non moi j'y
arriverai jamais c'est impossible
et peut-être même qu'un sentiment de
culpabilité et d'impuissance vous
envahir alors je vais être franche avec
vous pour en arriver là il m'a fallu
beaucoup de temps pas mal de stress et
beaucoup d'essence à parcourir les 10 à
20 supermarchés autour de chez moi à la
recherche de produits bio et vrac
avant d'en arriver à ce bocal je
traversais une sérieux des sérieuses et
profondes crises existentielles en bons
artistes que je suis pas j'étais au
chômage tout simplement
alors je cherchais un sens et un but à
ma vie et vous rajoutez à ça une
sérieuse dépression nerveuse qui se en
fait avéré être une mononucléose
ça vous donne une petite idée de ce à
quoi pouvait ressembler mais journée
[Musique]
avec le peu d'énergie qui me restait je
passais mon temps sur internet à la
recherche de vie plus épanouissante que
la mienne et un jour je découvre bea
johnson et son concept du zéro déchet la
révélation alors là mon esprit
écologique avait trouvé un nouveau
terrain de jeu j'ai fait littéralement
un bon sur mon canapé alors je
m'engouffre dans les méandres des
réseaux sociaux sur instagram sur
facebook partout à la recherche de
compte deux personnes
vantant les mérites d'un mode de vie
zéro déchet est alors certains étaient
même passé un bocal de déchets par an
plus petit que le mien c'est possible ça
parce que si les gens sur internet
peuvent le faire moi aussi parce que moi
aussi je voulais venir à bout de ces
déchets qui envahissent nos villes nos
villages nos campagnes en fait moi aussi
je le voulais mon trophée mon bocal de
déchets et puis quand je voyais les
photos que ses adeptes du zéro déchet
postés chaque jour sur leurs réseaux
sociaux j'avais l'impression que leur
vie est tellement plus heureuse que la
mienne je me suis alors persuadé qu'en
ayant des bocaux parfaitement alignés
sur mon étagère j'allais être heureuse
qu'en passant toutes mes courses en vrac
j'allais être heureuse et qu en
bannissant tout le plastique dans les
moindres recoins de chez moi j'allais
être heureuse alors il fallait que je
m'y mette
mais pour ça il fallait que je fasse
mieux que j'aille plus loin que je sois
parfaite
et puis il y avait un discours qui a
accompagné tout ça qui disait qu'il
était urgent de changer notre mode de
consommation et nos habitudes et la
passer au zéro déchet c'est devenu une
obsession voir une course à la
performance à l'excellence alors pour ça
je me suis fixé quelques objectifs au
très simple le premier c'était de passer
au zéro déchet et d'arrêter les courses
au supermarché
dès le lendemain il fallait qu'à la fin
de la première semaine
la poubelle et disparus de la cuisine et
que les paquets de riz de pâtes et de
gâteaux soient remplacés par des bocaux
alors très vite
je découvre un premier concept du zéro
déchet ledit hawaï le faire soi même
tout y passe un la lessive le dentifrice
justement tient alors une recette très
simple un basique trois produits qu'on a
à la maison
la première fois que j'en ai fait
j'ai vu mon mari et mon enfant revenir
vers moi
les gencives ans en me suppliant de
changer la recette
j'avais eu la main un peu lourde sur le
bicarbonate visiblement j'ai pas voulu
rester sur un échec et je me suis dit
tiens je me faire un petit plaisir je me
faire un petit masque bonne mine
je peux pas me tromper avec du miel du
curcuma et de la cannelle alors que je
voulais retrouver mon mon teint
d'adolescentes j'ai laissé le masque
posé un peu plus longtemps
oui oui la recette était très très
clairs à plus de cinq minutes
la cannelle ça brûle la peau alors oui
je me suis trompé
souvent et ça m'arrive encore surtout
j'ai voulu aller trop vite et je me suis
épuisé et surtout j'étais mais tellement
déçu de moi-même de ne pas coller au
perfectionnisme que je voyais sur les
réseaux sociaux que vous la première
semaine la poubelle était toujours dans
la cuisine
forcément j'ai commencé à culpabiliser
mais j'avais quand même une petite
satisfaction
oui j'avais découvert que bea johnson et
moi on avait un point commun tout comme
elle je commençais à sentir le cornichon
à force de me laver les cheveux au
vinaigre de cidre
mais je ne pouvais pas à lâcher il
fallait que je continue parce que
j'avais réellement conscience qu'en
passant un mode de vie zéro déchet
j'allais j'ai non seulement mon impact
sur l'environnement mais sur mon
portefeuille aussi ce n'est pas
négligeable
et puis franchement je ne pouvais plus
faire comme si je ne voyais pas ou que
je ne savais pas les montagnes de
déchets extinction de certaines espèces
le réchauffement climatique clairement
la planète ne digère plus nos excès
tient imaginer huit personnes enfermées
dans une 2 chevaux une deux chevaux qui
rouleraient sans jamais s'arrêter
d'accord c'est une personne ne peuvent
aller nulle part de toute façon ils
n'ont nulle part où aller
ces huit personnes dans la deux chevaux
consomme sans rien trier sans rien
recyclés et à un moment ça va poser
problème
entre les odeurs le manque de place la
pollution il ya un moment où trop c'est
trop
les études scientifiques sont formels
nous subissons actuellement une crise
environnementale sans précédent et ce à
échelle mondiale
ok donc là clairement ces moments on
aurait envie de s'écouter un petit
morceau de la compagnie créole 1 il sort
de pas trop déprimés ou et moi malgré
tous mes efforts malgré toute l'énergie
que je mettais à faire du zéro déchet
j'avais toujours cette impression de ne
pas en faire assez
et c'est là que j'ai dangereusement
glisser vers un burnout écologique
mais alors pourquoi pourquoi j'ai
continué à bas pour alimenter mes
réseaux sociaux par dix non sérieusement
j'ai continué parce que j'ai rencontré
d'autres personnes dans la même démarche
qui elle aussi avait les mêmes problèmes
les mêmes questionnements qui
culpabilise et beaucoup et puis au fil
de mes rencontres et de mes discussions
on m'a fait comprendre que chacun de mes
gestes
même le plus petit qu ils soient les
boutabout comptait alors j'ai commencé à
déculpabiliser et j'ai repris les choses
étape par étape et surtout je me suis un
peu des fêtes du diktat des réseaux
sociaux surtout quand j'ai compris que
c'était pas la vraie vie alors on a
repris les choses calmement tout le
monde à la maison a commencé à me suivre
et puis on a trouvé la démarche à la
fois plaisante l'amusante passé au zéro
déchet c'est une belle initiative mais à
l'évocation du terme
zéro déchet certains paniquent et
n'osent même pas passer à l'action
alors que d'autres voudraient égaler
mais ne savent pas comment faire non
mais tu te rends compte là il faut
sauver la planète
j'ai pas le choix il faut que je me
mette au zéro déchet mais entre les
gamins le boulot le ménage ma vie
sociale je sais pas comment faire c'est
peut-être votre cas alors on va se
détendre un peu non on va pas mettre un
manceau de la compagnie créole jouera
cieux on va faire baisser la pression
d'un cran et on va juste bouger le
curseur
on ne va plus parler de zéro déchet mais
de réduction des déchets ça va mieux
tout de suite non alors pour ceux et
celles qui voudraient se lancer dans
l'aventuré
je vais vous adresser un premier conseil
c'est celui que j'aurais aimé recevoir
quand je me suis lancé dans cette
aventure tout seul arrêtez de vous
comparer aux gens sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça vous évitera de vous mettre la
pression en rentrant chez vous ce soir
ne jetez pas votre poubelle et vos
bouteilles de gel douche par la fenêtre
quand vous en viendrez à vous laver avec
le liquide vaisselle
vous êtes sûr que vous n'allez pas du
tout apprécié si vous avez envie de
réduire vos déchets ne le fait pas parce
que vous vous sentez obligé personne ne
peut vous obliger à passer au 100 % à
zéro déchet dès demain 7le parce que ça
fait sens chez vous faites-le parce que
peut-être que vous trouvez ça fatigant
de sortir une poubelle trois fois par
semaine surtout l'hiver fait le pas ce
que vous avez déjà calculé combien vous
coûte cette petite bouteille d'eau en
plastique que vous achetez tous les
jours en allant au boulot la fin de
l'année faites-le parce que franchement
c'est pas très agréable de se poser sur
une plage où les cotons tiges ont
remplacé les coquillages sachez que
quelques gestes simples ne peut déjà
faire la différence alors nous par
exemple chez nous nous sommes tous
équipés d'une gourde
alors ce qui est génial c'est que
maintenant vous avez une telle variété
de couleurs de motifs que vous pouvez
l'assortir à votre paire de chaussures
préférées quand on achète le pain par
exemple on refuse le papier qui va
autour
est enlevé dans un sac tissus et puis
pour faire le ménage bas trois produits
suffisent du bicarbonate du vinaigre
blanc et un bon savon de marseille
alors même si mes déchets tiennent dans
ce bocal
je ne peux pas prétendre à une vie
parfaitement zéro déchet mais surtout je
déculpabilise jeu déculpabilise de
craquer encore parfois rarement sur un
paquet de chips
mais surtout je m'amuse je continue à
apprendre je continue à découvrir comme
par exemple comment faire mon yaourt
dans un bocal comme celui ci alors pas
celui ci comment faire ma lessive avec
le lierre au fond du jardin
et alors si vous saviez tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec des coquilles d'oeufs et
de peaux de banane aujourd'hui je peux
vous le dire franchement le zéro déchet
le minimalisme m'ont sauvé la vie oui
grâce à eux j'ai trouvé le but à ma vie
que je cherchais mon côté artiste a
rencontré mon côté écolo et ensemble
nous avons créé une confère une
conférence stand up dans laquelle je
partage mon expérience sur tous mes tops
et les flops dans ma quête du zéro
déchet et je le fais avec humour avec
autodérision et surtout avec beaucoup de
déculpabilisation parce que oui je suis
pour une écologie
souriante et puis-je accompagne aussi
les particuliers les entreprises à aller
doucement et sereinement vers cette
transition
quand les gens viennent me voir beaucoup
repartent déculpabiliser rassurer
motivés et prêts à passer à l'action
sereinement et d'autres un peu plus
sceptique peu nombreux me tiennent
encore ce discours
oui mais bon c'est pas juste
faisant ça qu'on va changer les choses à
votre niveau
acheter une gourde et du riz dans un sac
en tissu ça n'a pas sauvé la planète
non c'est vrai c'est vrai que vouloir
éteindre l'incendié d'une cathédrale
avec un verre d'eau
c'est soit très optimiste complètement
orgueilleux totalement stupide mais
imaginez que nous soyons millions avec
un verre d'eau imaginez toutes les
actions que vous pouvez mettre dans un
verre d'eau tout ce que l'on pourrait
accomplir
juste avec un verre d'eau on deviendrait
des super héros avec un verre d'eau
alors demain ou après demain quand vous
aurez envie de changer votre mode de vie
de passer à la réduction des déchets
dites vous bien que non ça c'est pas
comme ça même si on aimerait changer de
patron de pays ou de comptes en banque
ça demande du temps aujourd'hui j'ai agi
selon mes compétences mes capacités
le temps dont je dispose et surtout je
ne laisse ni ma santé ni mon argent vous
répondre à la question que vous vous
posez depuis le début il nous a fallu
deux ans pour arriver à ce bocal mais
très franchement le bocal
ce n'est pas l'objectif un proverbe
japonais dit en atteignant l'objectif on
a raté tout le reste
alors vous aussi dans les jours à venir
en mettant par exemple un stop pub sur
votre boîte aux lettres
en amenant une boîte chez votre
commerçant pour qu'il vous met le petit
morceau de fromage dedans en levant un
peu le nez de vos écrans dans seize
verdot dites vous que vous n'êtes pas
tout seul que vous n'êtes pas tout seul
à agir et que chacune des gouttes qui
composera votre verre d'eau contre
lorsque je vous propose c'est de vous
faire un beau cadeau une gourde pour
vous à sortir vos chaussures et un verre
d'eau pour la planète qui ne l'oublions
pas est la seule que nous ayons mais
surtout surtout prenez soin de vous
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]